so the thing that's definitely happening
in your world you're not challenging
yourselves to figure out other ways to
do content people get into ruts they
have something that works and they do it
for the next seven years like you have
to try different [__] like again the
thing I'm most proud of and I want you
all to go look at my last 100 posts on
Instagram we're trying all sorts of [__]
I'm saying the same [__] for 20 years
but if you find different creative ways
and you understand you can find that pay
dirt attention is the number one asset
hello hello hello ready rock and roll I
think I'm sure the teams prepped you for
this but
you know I think we've done this long
enough to know that you know what I
encourage you to do is like to go as
deep as possible to your actual question
uh it's cool that other people get value
from it but don't shy away from the most
nerdy nerdy detail because that's what
this portion is about so feel free and
it's nice to be with all of you how do
we not be commoditized against our peers
um you know if you look at the on the
field product of you know competitor of
the adult sports you know world over in
New Jersey it's very similar um so often
the first time we're compared to our
competitor like hey how come they're
$100 cheaper or you know this or that
why are they $100 cheaper
um that most people are just doing it
not to run a business and just kind of
as a passion project side hustle and not
really into make money they usually have
like side work or other work to do but
as you can imagine the consumer doesn't
care about that absolutely so from a
consumer standpoint what how do you
answer that yeah so well to answer the
question to them it's we're more
organized website we have backend uh
coordination of schedules and all this
other kind of stuff some people as you
can imagine are like take a picture of
the Google sheet email it out or text it
out or whatever so so first first you
feel like you will if they value their
time you can sell it back to them yes
right like yeah so I think I I always
think time is like the ultimate thing to
sell like there's people in here who've
literally ordered from Postmates a $4
candy bar and paid $27 in shipping just
so they didn't have to go downstairs in
in New York City to the local budha and
pick it up so you do answer that by
saying we save you time because of the
tech stack or don't you that's a
question to you
all um because I think I'm empathetic
that you may not realize how big of a
deal that is and it might seem like not
the biggest thing to sell on and I would
argue it's definitely something you
should sell on and in fact I would try
to like really think about it and get
into like text notifications and other
things because I think it's I always one
thing I really enjoying these things I
really pay attention right so you talk I
hear something I say why is it $100 more
you say well it's a side hobby for them
they're not writing the same p&l I'm
like that's good businessman stuff but I
don't give a [__] if I'm Johnny about
your problems I'm trying to save a
hundred bucks if you can then
communicate what the value props are
that will become really important
because nobody's commoditized it's a
really funny thought like everyone's
commoditized and no one's commoditized
like everything we're wearing right now
is actually commoditized yet we chose to
pay more for many different reasons um
and and everything else I think the
question becomes can you
articulate why you're a better option
like every single person here is looking
to articulate the value proposition in a
better way so that they get more people
to decide
them so I think you know I think keep
going besides that is there other things
that you can speak to in terms of the
value um because by the way it's okay to
go as blank as we think we run a better
ship yeah and it's it's worth more and
then if they say why you say like our
people are better you know we do think
we're saving you time and you're all
busy cuz the cool thing is the people
you're talking to you know are you know
it obviously runs the gamut but one of
the great things about being in the
tri-state area is everyone's busy yeah
like inherently it's in the DNA and the
fabric you know it's just in the energy
right um but I think right off the bat
for everybody and definitely for you is
like you you've got to be okay with
saying our people are better and thus
and for someone like me it be like well
yeah I want better refs or I want better
you know like when I walk into that like
I I don't know every detail yet but like
that no you're there I mean you know we
have we we St have site managers on the
field you know we're trying to get we're
coaching and training them to be more
personable get to know the captains on a
first a basis be able to communicate on
the field um we do a lot of uh showing
off the players in terms of MVP pictures
for every game we getting them posted on
social uh videographer how often is this
coming up the price is
push um not that often but I want to
increase the price but like bring the
value in in the same same way you know
yeah I think that's right you know I
think you know it's funny I grew up in a
liquor store called Shoppers Discount
Liquors price was what my dad traded on
and I got ingrained in that and and and
ironically even before I went to my
dad's liquor store my baseball card
business was based on price I would
literally walk the show in the eighth
grade as everyone was setting up
memorize all the prices of like the key
50 cards that everybody gave a [__]
about at the moment and go back and
repriced them cheaper like it was such
an easy thing to understand on price and
obviously over the last you know since
that kid over the last 40 years I
understand like there's many different
variables one can play on and you know
like now everybody wants to play the 1%
of the 1% because that's real good
business when you know playing price but
I I like where your head's at and I
would tell you and for everyone who's
listening as well with whether it's
Scots protein balls or anybody else in
between always challenge yourself of why
someone would pay for this at this price
is like like I don't know if there's a
day that I go by that I don't think
about that and I think most people don't
think about it at all and I think
there's something in there so I love
that that's where your heads at and
that's what leads to innovation of value
like all of a sudden here's a good
example the amount of people that want
to be sports broadcasters that are on
social media is like a billion just
adding a live stream component to every
game that's aired on Twitch to four
people but has a wannabe sportscaster
actually broadcast the game I would pay
for our back I would pay for that I'd
pay $ thousand dollars for that dinner
last night we were talking about like
what's could we make could we wck some
style follow one of the teams from the
league yeah I mean those are really fun
like clever ideas um I think that's cool
I think of that as like the sprinkles to
the Sunday and the Sunday has to be
something like we broadcast your games
and commentate
what's cool is the cost is nothing
you've got twitch you've got all these
live streams and again trate area has
advantages and disadvantages there's
just like literally a thousand people
who would work for nothing to be able to
call the game with the hope that they
get discovered that's why I like
challenging yourself of like what's in
it for them this that's what I think a
lot about like notice the example I gave
you twitch is free it's not like by the
way do you know why I used YouTube
Within weeks of it being available cuz 3
years earlier I tried to do Wine Library
TV and asked my tech team and they said
it was going to cost $50,000 a week cuz
streaming bandwidth cost in 2003 were
literally like $50,000 if like 10 people
watched three minutes and then you know
three years later YouTube was like it
literally took me like 20 minutes to be
like no no it's free like it's free like
I'll post it and YouTube's not going to
send me a bill it's funny to think about
those things so I think you're on a good
path keep try to add four more bills and
whistles that aren't your staff as nicer
those are right yeah yeah but you're
going to need like the thing on the
exactly the menu of like oh oh oh oh of
course 150 more yeah got it yeah by the
way you could go local college that has
a sports broadcasting thing because I
assume there'll be content at scale
right there's multiple leagues going on
at all the time and again you you could
also create teers so one of the ways you
could raise your price is whatever
imaginary price you had for increase you
might not do it for everyone you may
have a double that price for the SPO
Sports cast broadcasting way you can
still net out at the same Topline
revenue and have real justification of
why more yeah and that I just came up
with one idea in two seconds that I
think would work I think you keep
building on that yeah for sure do you
keep hardcore stats uh for basketball we
yeah yeah I mean I used to do it across
the board but it just got sloppy and
like 15% aside from basketball we're
looking at it so it was just like not
worth this yeah I think with that gets
me immediately into like really actually
producing meaningful actual trading
cards for everyone in the league with
actual stats on it there's just like you
just keep looking if you can just you're
just trying to ARB notice how he picked
up on like oh there's no risk like I'm
always thinking of like cost of goods
against perceived value yeah yeah right
right yeah yeah I I I like that you
started there and I would tell you that
that is a good Cadence forever I mean
there's a million ways to do this food
and beverage food and beverage could be
a
reason like where are you like
physically uh anywhere from we hawk and
a Wayne to withy that whole area kind of
thing a lot lot of W's there um uh I
really think that I really think that
the restaurant Sitch in Bergen and P
County also is like an opportunity maybe
you start using your business as a
platform for discovery of
food so like you reach out to all 7,000
restaurants that are on 80 and and 10
and say hey we have this we have captive
audience High net worth individuals that
are paying for this
would you like to Showcase you know
another reason is like our food and
beverage program is better another
notice what I did there lowc cost I'm
using my platform as a marketing engine
so I can ARB the cost of goods because
I'm not going to pay for that food but
there's perceived value on the other end
of people there and they yeah show up at
the field yeah like my number one thing
especially with buddies that I play with
is like oh we could eat afterwards and
shoot the [__] and talk [__] about the
game and just continuous stuff like that
yeah what else um tough one um growth in
New Markets so uh we came into New York
City last year uh stumbled a little bit
just in terms of bandwidth from running
in New Jersey coming to New York we
didn't have any foods on the ground in
in New York why' you come to New York uh
the lore of it yeah yeah 100% cuz then
you know we take a step back and we're
like what the hell like we're not even
in Hoboken you just took you just ate
every word out of my mouth like knowing
the size and scale of the New Jersey
market and knowing the supply and demand
of opportunity like when I think about
you going to living like the Livingston
Short Hills Milburn area and doing it
there versus playing here it's like you
haven't people do this all the time in
business yeah like they get excited
about expansion for the sake of
expansion like the thesis the the
ideology the the concept more than like
the actual business reality like this
business is way better executed in New
Jersey and Connecticut and Rhode Island
and all those places Manhattan just has
so much pull and cogs competitiveness
you know um yes ironically Hogs are very
very low for field space and that's like
one of our top things aside co uh hidden
cogs right fair fair got it yeah I'm
sorry I'm using my own slang you're
right more than I am energy yeah yeah
yeah your time is the number one Cog
yeah and especially living across there
you know what Crossing take I'm always
sad I do it plenty too which is this is
I think I'm giving therapy to myself
when you haven't fully squeezed the [__]
out of this grapefruit what the [__] are
you grabbing that orange for you know
what I mean like there's still a lot of
[__] juice here yeah totally I'm
sting my stopwatch because I am going to
be selfish this is a don't worry James
is I trust him more than anything but we
can double it up go ahead this this this
is a big day for me because I worked
hard to get back to this point um just
to give you some context well first of
all I want to say the reason I'm here
and you're always about context and
relevance I listen to your I listen to
the Gary V stuff that you repost through
my Spotify when I do cardio I think it
was on the first of the month this month
maybe last month October we run an
agency and you mentioned something about
like you know maybe you lost a big
client today you know right at the end
of the month often times agen turn over
that was super relevant then you guys
started talking about Sasha group and
4ds my assistant kind of look it up and
we booked so it's amazing thank you for
that feedback um but just uh here's my
Eric Godfrey moment okay
Eric Godfrey is the kid I met outside
when I was seven and he's when I
literally moved to Addison New Jersey
and they were throwing a Nerf football
and he said who do you like in football
and I said I was I was just in America
for a little while at this point he's
like well you're a Jets fan and that's
literally how I became a Jets fan and
it's like the Cornerstone of my interest
in life so here's my Gary Gary V Eric
godre uh I went bson College was one of
the Pioneers at premum MMS made a
shitload of money got invited to some
boat I'm on my way to the casino to to
roll craps with the founder of Groupon
and living social and my friend Ryan
cesler goes I'm going to see Gary vayer
Chuck you got to come with me you
weren't Gary be that you Gary and I said
who because I was into Tim Ferris
because I was I love him yeah Ryan
cesler who's just a an acquaintance of
mine goes Andy Tim Ferris Gary Vayner
and I walk in there you came out you
were I guess you were 35 at the time you
looked like you were 16 you're wearing a
shitty pair pair of cargo sh a t-shirt
that sounds exactly right you did the
best keynote speech I'd ever heard in my
life Gary comes out on stage and goes
I'm the most ruthless entrepreneur
you've ever met does his whole Spiel I
used to pick Po and looks right at
Russell Simmons and goes [__] you
Russell I did I did I did I remember and
that moment I've been the I've been all
in since anyway and by the way to give
me context so you don't think I'm a
complete jerk off what was and he's
painting a very clear picture what was
happening was everyone here was my point
I'm very good at at I'm a good public
speaker but I'm very good if I have a
lot of context so what was good about
this boat was I was speaking about a day
and a half in all I do is watch so I was
watching how everybody was rolling and
what I noticed was right you're probably
remembering more now even like I
couldn't believe how first of all this
was already a bougie [__] thing why
do you need to look at everyone's
[__] name tag before you decide how
important they are and this was at the
height of like Google and like and I was
just it was just very obvious to me that
like what people were doing and I was
like and I'm So Into like loving people
like blindly it's just so foreign to the
way I see the world especially because
everyone's on a journey which was the
point of like you don't get it I'm going
to be the most important guy here but
you don't know that yet and and what my
point was was like stop pegging everyone
let's spend the back half of this boat
just being nice to everyone you don't
know who you're going to meet one thing
you did on that trip too we got in a
like a Circle started with like three of
us then it was six I think by the end
maybe 10 people you stayed up all night
just talking to people I went to bed at
2: in the morning but I watched you walk
off that boat like going like this and I
was like what the [__] was the ROI and
that guy doing that but I mean it's just
amazing it's cool man I'm very humbled
thank you yeah go ahead um so anyway
it's been a long journey for me I got I
got into some legal issues in that
premium SMS space it took me out of the
game for six years I started working
with a with a Harvard neuroscientist uh
we were trying to sell a military grade
uh mental protocol to darpo which is the
advanced research in the military wasn't
making any money doing it but it dialed
me the [__] in when I got out of that
kind of six years of kind of going
through legal Health Y and this guy you
know he's doing brain mapping and all
this stuff I've been sober for seven
years I eat organic I meditate I do all
this [__] he really dialed me in and but
I was making three grand a month wasn't
wasn't doing much and all of a sudden
pandemic comes and I'm the most calm
clear-minded version of myself ever I'm
sitting my parents home in Cape cot I
get a call from a girl who who
remembered me when I was this young
highflying internet marketer Andy need
your help I've got $100 to my name I'm
some Jewish ladies nanny in La doing her
grocery shopping I'm stressed out about
getting coron virus so only fans but I
can't figure it out yeah so what the
hell is that I logged in I said oh wow
you're trying to thirst got no marketing
logic really robust in the sense that it
can you know s make these transactions
but it doesn't do a good job of taking a
crater with a blindfold on and saying do
steps one through 10 and you're going to
make it back yeah yeah girl had 50,000
followers on Instagram no Tik Tok no
twitch no Twitter no nothing wasn't a
Creator I shoved her out of the way and
I started to storytellin made her a
quarter of a million dollar in a month
she starts running around La starts
telling all these Instagram people uh
hey don't trust your business to night
promoters and right you know there's
these guys in Boston and it exploded and
it what what's happened is the owners of
that platform who are Ukrainian Russian
guys um they they now they now use us
basically when they've got larger
celebrities like Denise Richards MIAA
people like that that they can see on
the back end aren't quite taking
advantage of their opportunity they
bring them to us here's here's why I'm
here built this company to $100 million
a year company without a brand and
without uh without putting content on
the internet and it was all these kind
of intellectual face-to-face zooms where
I would get on the you know get on
FaceTime with these content creators and
really say like hey if you get a fan
when you attract an audience you can
make $5 off them or 5,000 off them
what's the difference that's what we
bring to the table the analytics the
Special Sauce oh my God I didn't know
you existed
da after about year three I said it's
time to Brand this thing so we built our
brand creators Inc and went all in on
that we just had this big house party
with Steve aoke we activated New York
Fashion Week so all of our clients who
don't just want to be only fans creators
could come and walk on a Runway we do
stuff like that yep problem is now that
we've this big fancy brand they're not
coming like they were when I just got on
FaceTime with them and I was like you
know what's quantitative analytics like
how what's a wall post for what's this
for what's that for is that a macro or
micro thing do you think because the the
space is more mature as well like I
think a lot of times people remember
when we lost a Subway pitch and I was
shocked were you here for that we like
we won like 13 pitches in a row and then
like subway said no and I was like
baffled I was like how is that possible
and what I didn't realize at the time
was uh-oh when we said social media in
201 like 10 and 11 people were like okay
like like my brother's laptop literally
created the Pepsi and NHL and Campbell
Soup like Facebook and Twitter like it
was that early obviously as that
ecosystem has evolved that's why I'm
asking you do you think it's a macro or
micro issue it's a micro because uh well
that's then then that's golden if you
believe that it's micro you just go back
to the number one thing that always
Works in business which is and it's I
can't believe the fact that your story
touched on this what was the ROI of that
guy doing it scaling the unscalable
always works the cool part is your story
is so simple right why don't you just go
back and do that now you may not want to
and that's awesome that's okay because
then you can have a diluted version of
that meaning you hire other people like
nobody sells the way I sell my stuff but
if I was the only person doing that then
it would only be what it is so I'm okay
with the B and the C and the B minus and
the a I mean you're thrilled when it's
the a minus version of what you do so
all you'd have to do is replicate what
you would do one-on-one with the Navy
Seals and the Green Beret not the
general Army that your 100 million is
you have to build a Navy SEALS or a
Green Beret to be an A minus B+
hopefully B no worse than B minus
version of you doing it and you're also
allowed to go back and do it as often as
you want to there's an interesting VAR
so one of the reasons I never just took
the content of me you know pitching and
selling and talking about quanti well
that I understand why well there's two
ways that people think about that one
they don't want to be out in front like
that's just a human thing which is very
real you're allowed or not allowed and
two some people fear that they go too
far in the details of it and people can
replicate it yeah and specifically in
our case what I didn't want to do was
piss off the partners that that only
fans to be like oh when you're chatting
with so and so you're actually talking
to us so we were respecting that well
that I I respect that because a lot of
people because a lot of people screw up
and do that and then they just kind of
get you know they they they get nixed
for that but we're kind of coming to the
point now where I mean a lot of our a
lot of our marketing was trying to say
things without saying things and that's
where I think we were screwing yeah that
makes sense that's where we were
screwing up that go I mean that the
number one business that sucks is that
at some level you can get humongous but
it's going to weigh the other thing is
just on a side note the other thing you
have to think about is just the business
itself because that work is going to get
aied out for real actually for real
actually like of is going to do that not
let you do that there's you're right I
mean but in in a lot of ways I think we
know where AI is going to really help in
the space versus like some of the parts
where you would think that it might
completely take over yeah I would say
this and I and I actually am a buyer of
what you just said just do me a favor CU
I don't I want you to win never underes
estimate technology it's always like
it's back to the era we met that next 10
years I watched so many people say
versions of that CAC roow you know this
I don't have to tell you so just and
this one's such big technology I would
argue even the people that are deepest
about it are potentially underestimating
how gnarly this Tech is so I just want
to make sure you keep that in mind I
think the number one thing that everyone
should always be doing is putting
themselves out of business before
someone else does I think you should go
all in on assuming that truth and work
backwards instead of whatever version of
Hope of what variation it becomes
because I think that will lead you to
innovate the next thing I just want to
tell you there's a lot of Gary ve in our
business so for instance like when I
when I coach content creators and we
talk about context right yeah can I
throw a left field at you thing at you
that's I'm just feeling so much I have
to say it I highly recommend and I think
you will based on everything I've heard
please when you leave here please debate
starting a consumer product yeah so I'm
in charge of growth right all these
things are we're looking at like we have
a large roster every day we see clients
of ours their content is getting ripped
and turned into Snapchat or original
shows right so like as we grow we talked
about this a little bit earlier too
right like we're trying to figure out
how to
navigate there's this concept of people
gatekeeping a good service when they
find it in our industry right of course
as we've now started posting content
we're like how do we navigate going from
Top tier service that's behind the
scenes to now kind of Walmart
distribution in terms of media and kind
of navigating that content chain I think
a I think that's right B I'm talking
about starting a cereal yeah no or like
a handkerchief by the way we have to
show you serial creators cuz on one of
your things you talked about like eating
cial on podcast yeah serial entrepreneur
I started something called serial
creators breakfast creator Cal cereal
Creator cereal breakfast or cereal
cereal Creator anyhow last thing I want
to plant in your head just so know um in
case you ever have anything to throw um
out of nowhere We've Ended up with
clients like Denise Richards like aelia
like you know these typ well not out of
nowhere it sounds like you're great at
your craft and the platform benefits for
you making people that should be winning
win so much I would argue it's the least
out of nowhere thing so much so that uh
agents like UTA looked at buying us
because afraid Emily Rakowski was going
to come to us make 400 Grand a month and
only fans and then we'd say we'll do
your brand deals for free emails right
your higher value um and I just kind of
wanted to obviously like you've been in
the service business for I'll give that
some thought cool send me an email after
this I'll keep it I I know where to put
it one other selfish question I have is
you were talking about twitch for them
we're very tapped into culture like we
have kids that are some of the bigger
IRL streamers y like St kick or twitch
like where do you see that evolving you
see I think it's Jack any of those I
mean yeah I get it all of it is going to
end up going to the blockchain because
even all of those exist because they're
all scared to get banned for cancelling
on something so you have these we won't
ban you until that becomes the it's
always there's centralization and
decentralization right this is why
people are grossly underestimating the
blockchain in the geopolitics that the
world is in in the media landscape that
we live in there is an inevitable
outcome of an and to the world we live
in now it's not like a decentralized
social network or streaming service is
going to put out of business twitch or
Facebook of the day in five years but
both will exist and the best which is
the game you're playing in the best will
all gravitate to
decentralization once they extract
attention from
centralization you know this all the
creators are like yo [__] V I remember
when the vine guys and girls went to
vine to go yell at them and I was like
tell me how that works out and I also
tried to remind them that they were
[__] babysitters and working at
Starbucks until the attention that sat
on Vine came to them so how that's how I
think they'll work out you streaming it
all on Twitch or my I'll get I'm going
to go around because I don't want James
to get mad at me the quick answer is I'm
not because I don't think people
understand that I work 24 hours a day
I'm one of the most prolific content
creators but I allocate zero minutes a
day to content creation I wish I could I
want to tell you only reason I asked
that is because what we've noticed in
our
space I get it trust me the problem is
I'm inclined if it was old Wine Library
days all of it because I'm sitting with
sensitive information that is that I can
get that I just have you'd be stunned
how little people who are crushing it
all all they really have versus the
people who aren't is good spatial
awareness with them and their I couldn't
agree more they're just
doing man I so I so see it I get it
trust me I've been thinking about it a
lot you stream ended up being a huge
factor to me back in that those days not
just Twitter and Facebook the early
streaming stuff all right let me keep
going you uh yeah what's going on
Vancouver yeah you uh well first book
was crush it you actually talked about a
realtor that started on YouTube started
filming himself in his car that Realtor
is Ian watt yep I remember who I
actually consider somewhat of a friend
that's awesome and so I kind of ended up
just following that blueprint and um end
up building a very good personal brand
and awesome real estate space um you
know like big you know we be on
Bloomberg interviewing you know CBC news
but I guess the issue that I'm having or
I'm here as a personal brand trying to
figure out sort of where my next move or
where do I pivot but the residential
real estate space I find is very hard to
scale and so I'm like it's it's a [__]
business to scale so I'm like most are
yeah and so I think I'm just looking
ahead as you know I've been doing it now
for 10 years I'm still a young guy I'm
like now started this podcast it's
called The Looney hour and what's that
about so it's it's myself I look at it
from the real estate space
cuz space I've partnered up with the guy
that runs portfolios he's like a macro
macro investor basically runs uh client
portfolios he's a money manager he's a
money manager Y and then the other guy
was uh worked for a hedge fund he love
it so you guys shoot it yeah so that we
basic we literally just shoot the sh how
old are you uh 32 yeah I mean this is
perfect for me to answer so from you
know from from 30 from 30 to
34 you know when I was Gary vaynerchuk I
was the wine guy just like you're the
real estate guy in Vancouver I decided
to start making content about other
things as a personal brand who's built
something you got to understand back to
what he he was just talking about it's
not just your pretty eyes like you have
other communication capabilities charism
so you could actually employ that to
anything else that you can speak to I
decided to go very macro and go into
overall communication and then that led
me to like the insights of like how
humans I went through a really weird
period where I was like I'm literally
telling everybody what to do I'm like do
this on Facebook and I'm like no one's
doing it and that led me to like oh
people are insecure people like people
do like all the [__] I talk about but I
could have went into like I thought
about it sports like I'd be McAfee
that's why Pat and I are friend like I
whatever I was going to do it was going
to work I just chose a certain Lane you
know I think what you need to do is
decide what if it's what's next or I
don't want to scale this you that
blueprint continues to be true the
platforms change the best practices
within them change but back to what
these gentlemen were just talking about
whether it's streaming and spatial
recognition and storytelling to the
mundane whether it's the ne I mean the
next Tik Tock is always one day away it
will happen you know it could be seven
years it could be four years but even
back to like the the nerd of all this
like the amount of money creators could
be making on Snapchat because of the
supply and demand of how much ad revenue
is in there versus how many people
create for it because everyone's fixated
on Tik Tok and Instagram is enormous and
then o goes from thirst traps to a
broader market and patreon there's just
like a million things going on I think
your biggest debate at this young of an
age is what is your favorite stuff you
can only win on passion or knowledge
like like like someone like you there's
a lot of ways to win but you my gut
based on what I'm hearing you're going
to win on either you love the [__]
Canucks more than
breathing or you really know something
else well I went with the well and
passion right I went wine business
marketing um you know I think I think
you have a pretty clear like what's also
cool about the core real estate business
is it's not like you have to retire the
fact that you can start something around
Pokemon video Gam games table tennis
pool whiskey while still doing the real
estate St and then integrating it the
way I do cuz I'm all over the [__]
place you might get a [__] garage
sale video for me or a Jets video or
business or like you know like I don't
think people realize the renaissance man
and woman thing is very real everyone's
like you got to stay consistent the bad
advice don't worry about it I'm not
distracted um uh the bad advice that
people go and be like pick your Niche
and go yes but then once you have your
steak you can sell mashed potatoes you
could sell green beans that what do you
think's going to happen brother you
think somebody in Vancouver is going to
see a video about you talking about
whiskey and being like oh he also likes
whiskey I can't take him serious about
real estate people don't deploy common
sense to this conversation they talk
Academia so where I'm seeing that
crossover just for an example is our
loona show is now like it's like the
finance show in Canada like that's
awesome come into that full Canada like
full Canada that's awesome so it's doing
well the nice thing about that right
Vancouver you're you're set to that
geographical limit of constraints right
your client tell only to be people that
like yeah of course buy and sell in
Vancouver like now we're opening up to
Canada um like we're literally
interviewing like former Prime Ministers
and stuff like that and it's Leen for
all of you right Leen but for them too
they're very broad where you're narrow
yes I'm narrow I'm getting a lot of
clients that they like hey I listen I've
been listening to L for last 12 months
have you have you thought about building
a a nation brokerage there's I don't
think there's a lot of good M maybe it's
cu the CES it's a little bit different I
think it's I think the brokerage model
is [__] I think it's actually dying okay
where I do I think this is kind of
leading and some of my question is so my
co-host who's the money manager uh he
wants to actually sort sort of help he
wants me to help him scale his business
and take you know Equity stake because
basically what's through that podcast
yep unintentionally he's pulling in like
he's signing out two to three new
clients a week not unintentionally which
yeah in that industry is you know most
people will generate their business by
all all of this conversation for
everyone is just brand is the
bestselling yeah I always make fun of
people who like don't believe in
marketing and branding who are great
sales people I'm a great salesman too
I'm like cool that's like that's like
when you're not good at marketing and
sale and brand you like you guys are
it's not unintentional it's called you
built you built brand which is why he
has
wouldn't worry necessar about a
crossover of like Oh Real Estate and
then sort of on the portfolio management
side he's like oh now he's kind of doing
that thing well let's play it out I
think when you hear it played out in
conversation you realize how silly it is
what do you think like what do you
think's going to happen people are like
what what happened like maybe last like
oh I think he's not you know do I want
to hire this guy cuz he's not fully
dedicated to would you take my wine
recommendation that's the answer to the
question yeah right well you've proven
your worth in that other space and the
only reason why I look at that is
because like so his competition which
like the whole industry in portfolio
management is regulated by investment
advisers that work for big Bank big Bank
says you cannot do social media at all
you want to send a tweet like we need to
get compliance oh I'm very aware there's
plenty of versions of that all over the
world so I'm just looking at that and
saying I feel this this huge white space
opportunity of course it is have zero
competition the banks are unwilling to
correct yeah yeah I don't think you'll
lose your whole real estate Empire in
Vancouver cuz you've also started to
play in the money management space and
that's assuming you go front-facing yeah
well that's the thing I think
realistically i' actually end up
probably more behind the scenes exactly
like I'm not going to be the one that's
physically managing someone's money
corre the guy that's building that
business correct so notice what I notice
the clarity I just gave you on that
sounds like you're worrying about
something that won't even manifest yeah
no that's fair I think it's like I think
it's but this goes back to like what we
yeah yeah like I think this is what we
do yeah like I I if you just listen like
well they are not running real business
consumer doesn't care these are
philosophical things we think stay on
brand people don't care what what do we
not willing to take Mark Walberg
seriously as an actor because he was
once Marky Mark you know what I mean
like we do this thing and I'm telling
you it's all grounded in Academia it's
not grounded in real market dynamics the
consumer has spoken on this issue will
change our mind and if you show me
enough of you're this you're this Mike
Bloomberg used to be a sass entrepreneur
to me then he became a mayor like I
don't know like you become what you are
at a consistent Pace both good bad and
different so I don't fear that
especially it sounds like you have like
yours is really fun because doesn't
sound like you're even going to confuse
the market yeah well I mean it's just
nice to already have like the platforms
and the brand is already built so it's
obviously just kinding to leverage that
into like a more scalable business that
I feel like okay where do I see
myself I think that makes sense I think
where you took it to a little bit of an
interesting place it sounds like you're
fearing something that can't happen yeah
yeah I think ultimately like right
you're going to be behind the scenes
kind of feels like I'm asking for
permission but like no by the way by the
way the good news is that's a really
good observation I think we all do that
yeah I think we all like this is why I
believe in therapy the most sometimes
you already know the answer you just
need to talk it through yeah it's just a
human trait for all of us I guess my
last question quickly was uh so now
again if you had I know you got your
podcast but if you had one
recommendation uh for scaling like my
podcast is there anything that you see
as like a huge opportunity it's like oh
people like people that have an audio
video podcast they should totally be
doing this yeah I mean I think I think
I'm incredibly consistent about this I I
believe that if everyone here so I'm
writing a new book called day trading
attention right I believe that we all
have to day trade attention to maximize
our upside what that means is you need
to pay attention to everything that is
going on so B let's just use scaming
because I fully agree with these guys
what's going on there like I was one of
the people early on that was like Hey if
you have a podcast film it and then
post- produce it and put it everywhere
now that's incredibly common practice
but I would also argue that you should
stream it as well have four twitch
followers at first like while you're
doing the now again everybody has a
different process for me everything's
always worked cuz I'm happy to just like
put it out there obviously when you film
something you have the ability to post-
produce it if you're live you're live so
like if you're just if you go live and
you're waiting for your guest you might
not want to do that live you know like
you got to think about what live means
but look I think linkedin's organic
reach is something everyone under
leverages on this day as we all sit here
today I think people understand you can
go viral on Tik Tock though that's much
harder than 3 years ago I don't think
people understand how consistently you
could can get organic reach that you
didn't have the day before on LinkedIn
and I'm very bullish on it I and I think
everybody here whether you sell a
protein ball or you're actually in the
B2B business LinkedIn is more Facebook
2015 than it is the LinkedIn that I
think everyone defaults into thinking it
is so would say anybody who's not
Distributing any of their content
everybody should be Distributing content
in LinkedIn it's a really good
psychology audience too the human that's
on LinkedIn when they're consuming
LinkedIn is a different version of
themselves often very business
transactional minded versus Tik Tok
where you're just looking for escapism
or or you know entertainment I'm very I
would say that one really stands out for
me but then also just taking no
assumptions you need to film them and
you need to post- produce them but you
also have to be great at the post-
production I know we'll touch on that I
don't know how much have we touched on
that yet or is that in back half have we
done sock stuff a little
bit you know so like this stuff like the
world works on storytelling first of all
thanks we uh we kind of built uh Studio
on the heels of like thank you
and so thank you that's good so so since
then over nine years we've grown to be
uh kind of a collection of businesses
that are like over100 million uh and we
only about 200 people on our team um we
primarily grew with Instagram so we like
we started um because we got on there
and kind of pulling back the curtain on
like highend design kind of make it more
um kind of like approachable and be able
to answer a bunch of questions so we've
basically grown primarily most of our
business off organic content and it was
just like telling the growing the brand
brand above everything telling that
whole story um was really successful
drove a lot of business and I think now
we're at a stage where um we are adding
in p and we're trying to really measure
the attribution and within within an
Instagram envirment
yeah Instagram we're on Tik Tok um we we
had a Netflix show for like four seasons
oh wow that ended last season so when we
first launched Netflix we saw an
incredible like lift and like kind of
like what was the show about called
Dream Home Makeover would just they took
kind of what we did to F it down we go
in and like put over like a room y yeah
I mean obviously in the beginning that
must have been huge awareness so you're
just feeling a maturation standpoint
right now yeah which is why paid has
entered yeah makes sense you kind of
like just seen this mean reversion in
the home industry over the last like I
say like year like there was a big bom
like a big big bomp during Co and then
when people were kind of all their house
like of course of course of course bup
in my services businesses and now it's
kind of like okay where we at who's
who's left this is my father calling me
every day he's like why are we not
selling as much wine as we did during Co
I'm like Dad people are not at their
home 24 like I'm sorry Like Somebody
went to a restaurant tonight and ordered
a glass of wine that came out of your
pocket he's like you have to fix it I'm
like
geez like thank you for the confidence
but I'm like I can't change the world
yeah so I think that's kind of where
we're left is like okay we can either
right size business a little bit more
which we have we like like we really
like looked at business operations like
hard core went really efficient but
after having this kind of run it's in
your tummy to just want to continue to
grow instead of be more efficient right
yeah doubled every year for the last of
course four five years so here's the
cool it's really funny because thank you
economy and Jab jab jab right hook day
trading attention 6 months ago was
called jab jab jab left hook it's I'm
literally rewriting the book because
it's changed so much and I'm ready for a
301 course instead of the 2011 that that
book was at the time the cool part is
organic is here it's just that you're
not good at Tik Tok organic is here it's
just that you haven't even committed to
LinkedIn and then thus can't be good at
it so couple things one you've won
between Netflix and Instagram and that
run on awareness leading to to sales
that is still on a table for all of us
it's just a lot harder right
now right that that's all that's
happened but it's actually never been
greater it's like this weird thing it's
like there's always ab and flows it's
why I was so and I know it sounds like a
lot of you have had contacts on me for a
long enough time it's why I was so loud
pandemic was March 2020 it was why I was
so loud late 18 all of 19 about Tik Tok
the land grab of organic was better than
anything Instagram ever had but nobody
moved because everyone was pot committed
Instagram so couple things one let that
little thing because you'll always
clearly what you have resonates you just
need to ARB attention versus value like
to
right just make sure that every time
there's another new thing especially if
I'm loud about it because that means it
already happened I'm not guessing to go
triple hard I remember I promised myself
before Tik Tok if I ever saw another
YouTube YouTube Twitter Facebook
Instagram Vine that I was that was it I
was going to go into a cocoon I wasn't
even going to run Viner I was going to
be one cuz I knew it and sure enough
musically came Tik Tok came I saw it I
did great but I [__] went like 20%
hard cuz I had other
responsibilities and boy do I wish I
went 100% hard cuz it may be a long time
before we have as big of a moat of
opportunity as Tik Tok 1819 was anyway
that's all to be said that when they get
into brand forance later like there's
definitely a play media is great like I
think people get religious especially
when they're great at organic like I'm I
grew all this without media I'm like
that's not a badge of
honor I'm like if you're a media
right and I get why I get why it goes
back to a lot of what we're talking
about here like the subconscious but
when you really break it down but if you
could spend media perfectly and it would
grow your business why wouldn't you like
you know you get caught in these like
ideologies so I think a don't demonize
paid paid scary because like it feels
really hurtful when you like spend
$100,000 and nothing
happens external agency like they try to
take credit for a lot right so they're
like hey like contributing like 25% of
your Revenue you're like bro you just
got here like two like six weeks ago
100% I I always make fun of our team I'm
like we we every time a business is
doing well you all say we did it and
every time it's not doing well it's
their fault I'm like you hypocrite
you know um yeah no I think you should
build this
internally I think most I I say it all
the time to clients all the time this is
why I think Sasha group and Vayner do
well I'm like why would you hire us it
goes back to what I was saying earlier
the price I'm always like why would
someone hire us this what we're doing we
like I really think about 4ds a lot I'm
like why like we put this video out like
I'm like I think about this [__]
constantly like why why why so anyway
couple things for your business
couple really interesting things I don't
have the full answer on this but I'm
spending a lot of time on Pinterest
personally right now for your business
Pinterest is bananas it's just that
Pinterest has never found its moment of
like what we're all looking for like
that true organic monster but I would a
flirt with that a little bit YouTube
shorts is very important for all of us
because YouTube's the second biggest
search engine in the world and your
business is very search oriented like
when people go their journey and
obviously they're doing that more and
more on social but I think YouTube
shorts is a very big deal these are the
platforms that I think you have to get
as good you have to understand you have
to give yourself more credit for getting
good at Instagram back in that era I
think a lot of times when people have
organic Pay Dirt they give the platform
credit not themselves now some things
come more natural to people than others
one of the biggest reasons people didn't
jump into Tik Tok is it didn't feel
natural to them it's by the way it's a
challenge for me because I don't create
Tik Tok you have to really create
like my post- production [__] does not
work on Tik Tok the same way I just have
no options I'm doing too many other
things so I'm going to have to take that
L and be like a c minus at it my wife
hates it CU she's become like the face
of our business right yes and she's like
damn it like all the Tik toks that do
really was it's like me talking want
they want to see me just talking I want
to get on every day I'm old 39 be 40
you're so young you're fine you know but
she's like those just do really resonate
yeah I think I mean look I think I think
that the game for you is to get paid and
organic to work well on every platform
to the best of your ability and to back
to the different ideas that I was
talking about over here for for ideas
for business I think the thing I'm most
proud of and I hope you've all felt this
is like when you go to my grid it's like
a popery of Randomness everyone's so
obsessed with their grid being on brand
it's just not how people consume they're
consuming content to content content so
the thing that's definitely happening in
your world if your wife's like [__] this
[__] I don't want to do this every day
you're not challenging yourselves to
figure out other ways to do
content people get into ruts they have
something that works and they do it for
the next seven years like you have to
try different [__] like again the thing
I'm most proud of and I want you all to
go look at my last 100 posts on
Instagram we're trying all sorts of [__]
pouring [__] milk into coffee to say
be you like I'm saying the same [__] for
20 years but like but if you find
different creative ways and you
understand you can find that pay dirt so
like maybe it's just audio maybe the two
of you should have dinner where you know
you're recording the dinner and you like
know you're recording it and it's all
audio and you just literally like talk
about [__] that you want like to get out
there and that's your podcast and maybe
that's your creative Pay Dirt cuz that
would be like some [__] that I would
listen to if I gave a [__] about a
couple just them having dinner like
literally two post carousels what's yep
still working but like again I'm already
feeling the you know it's just date
that's why I'm calling it day trading
attention I'm trying to get people out
of the rud of like oh this works they
think it works for like the next nine
years you got to be in it you've just
you've hit that place we all have hit
fatigue of the style of the creative or
the distribution of the creative you got
to challenge yourself does that make
sense introducing new people you know
when a sitcom has a great run and it's
getting a little tired they bring in
like the kid like that [__] weird kid
for you know the Brady Bunch and even
Leo DiCaprio I think was like the kid
for growing pains like they're you know
like to spice it up Cosby Show I think
out a like every great sitcom when it
gets tired introduces that new character
with the hope you know like you may want
to introduce a new character to your
ecosystem I think that's what we're just
thinking about like as we introduce new
things trying to measure that to like
that that is work you know you know
what's funny like you got to make sure
you have patience in that it's funny
like always think about your purest self
when you were winning and then realize
after levels of success how you're no
longer that person me holding on to 2005
Gary is probably my best business move
because you weren't [__] Roi
measuring in 2014 Instagram the way you
are now you've become mature you've
become corporate you're looking for Raz
and CAC and LTV acronyms you didn't even
know what the [__] they meant eight
years ago when it started popping off
2005 Gary still runs this as a matter of
fact you know this you guys know this
2005 Gary or 2011 Gary if we're talking
bner terms came back a couple years ago
and right and it's been way better
right because I I wanted to learn what I
I didn't know what I didn't know so I
started bringing in more of corporate
agency DNA over like a 5year period and
then I knew what it was and I was like
all right I'll keep the 3% of this
garbage that I like and we're going to
go back to 97% me and boy right you
right it's like and across forget about
feelings like the p&l shows it and it's
just real life this whole content is is
you now y we done y so themes that work
right yeah that thanks I'll end here um
just external like generating like uh
let's see taking advantage of like
external media opportunities right we
have a bunch com our way now versus just
deciding to go in house with gener is
there a way that you like kind of
evaluate that to make that call like he
like do your own show on YouTube just
press that because I think it's an I
think it's and now if you're saying show
like obviously an external production
company like I think right now if you're
off the air which it sounds like you are
I do my own show immediately so when the
next production company comes and wants
you to do something you're like yeah but
I'm keeping my show I'm like yeah you
can do that we're going to do a
different version here so that would be
on my mind on strategy hey hi started my
consulting firm back in 2005 as an
insourced um with an insource B embedded
model for General Market ad agencies and
so we would Place Consultants onsite at
a ad agencies throughout New York and
that worked and we grew for about seven
to maybe 10 years and what would
agencies hire you to come in they hired
us to do to manage to develop and manage
their Supplier Diversity initiative love
so that's great keep going it's awesome
and I was hired as the first
Supplier Diversity director makes so
much love it unfortunately we we're
having the conversation in 2023 that we
had back in
2025 2015 you mean I mean that we had
back that we had in 20 I mean 205 got it
yeah yeah no worries I'm just trying to
make sure I'm hearing it right no keep
going and so the the challenges we're
having are are few developed um a
platform in 16 in order to scale because
hiring Consultants placing them on site
that's really an expensive business yes
right and so a lot of what we do are the
analytics the database management you
know just the is it a SAS based business
yes SAS based business fully funded
amazing and so and we built it we get
feedback that it's an amazing
platform since holding companies have
now come in and centralized resources
and are having a and since they own
almost every single agency bingo bango
there you go makes sense and our
relationships were at the agency level
right can you create and yeah the this
is what sucks the business needs to go
into
smaller right because the place you can
get independence is 10 million in
revenue and lower right before the
holding Co buys it right the problem is
those companies are so small that
they're just trying to keep the lights
on they're not even thinking de Andi you
know it's not that they're bad people
right it's just like they're like [__]
I'm not sure I'm going to be in business
next year and we're on the compli side
right you got to have a c that really is
requiring this in order for you to bring
us in to do it and so my my business
manager is suggesting that we break up
the from the company well we did that
initially but he he's talking about
breaking it out up into smaller modules
so that we can sell it at a lower price
point but I think to your point because
what I've what I've experience in this
industry is that it's it's just as
difficult to sell $5,000 as it is to
sell 50,000 right yep there both Theses
are right you know I could tell you back
to more Gary Consulting items as
gateways to a since I know I can talk to
you in these terms has worked for us you
know cuz we had a very hardcore get out
of bed fee to do what we do best and we
think you know and so I do think cost
aventry is a variable I equally agree
with you that sometimes it's just as
hard same effort to sell something for
5,000 is 5 million let alone 50,000
that's real too you know I'm not against
modularizing down if you're asking one
man's subjective point of view I what I
like about it is it will give you more
clarity I always like eliminating things
that you're debating for everyone like
what I like about the modularity of like
how much is it now per month per year
it's 180,000 right and he's saying or
she's saying instead of 15K a month
let's have some sort of product that's
3K and you can Voltron it up and
discount it here's why I like it my
biggest concern is that there's six
holding companies they're full of [__]
and there is no business to be
had what I like about dropping it from a
180 commitment to a 36k commitment if
you've got some modula 3K is you'll find
out in a year if I'm right because
that's a real low cost and that should
be easy and if you go 0 for 90 with a 3K
thing right then you could say wait a
minute I gotta really think about this
[__] and do I need to become like the
Nintendo company and that analogy for
everyone is they used to be a trading
card not a trading card like a playing
card company Nintendo started as like
black jack cards and at some point they
pivoted into technology what I love is
your expertise and your career and what
you've got going this goes into like
really interesting debate that everyone
should be thinking about always think
about things that you have permission to
do that you can't see like if if you
emailed me in 9 months which you're more
than welcome too and on a long flight I
get to that level of email priority and
you're like hey thank you this is not
fun to write because I did break it down
I did go to market and for the last
seven nine months 15 months we're not
selling anything even at three you're
right it is full my reply would be like
listen now you need to think about
should you be an author should you
change it into a experiential company
because maybe you shouldn't be selling
it to Tech or cios maybe you should be
selling to HR as a one- day Retreat to
rethink things like you could like
what's amazing is the talent you had as
a kid in the SMS thing that became the
that became the seeds of the thing that
you we have our things and sometimes you
just got to repackage it into a
different item and remark you know
containers and Merchandising right
container and Merchandising that's what
we're all in and so that's something
worth debating no thank you cuz the cuz
the you know what's great about you know
when when he said we're getting old 3940
I was laughing right and I saw you
Snicker like I saw I saw I saw and I
think you know what's really cool like
one big issue I have with the world that
I'm excited to like I finally going to
eat my own dog food and do something
I've been wanting to do which is I'm
going to go and um donate my time to
retirement homes but I'm also going to
capture content because I realized as a
young kid even at 6 7 8 9 10 I spent an
ungodly amount of time with people that
were 80 and 90 that weren't my
grandparents and for a long time I
thought it was because I only had one
grandma and one great- grandma in my
whole life CU unfortunately everybody
died in Russia pretty early um but now
I've come to realize no I've always just
been attracted to macro thinking and
wisdom and things that nature and right
now I think we can all agree by the way
50 years ago in America our grandparents
were on a pedestal wisdom and experience
was on a pedestal today we are all
living where Youth and technology is on
a pedestal 24 year olds are running
around my company thinking they should
be running this place right that's the
era we're in which means we're going to
go back this how the world works so I'm
excited about wisdom and experience
gaining momentum in the next two decades
and I think your timing like I just
think it's important for you to hear
that cuz I think when I hear that
narrative and like first of this and
this that and it's a really important
issue like it actually matters and I
really do think this is a Young Person's
game and so yes but I I think we're yes
but I really do think that trading on
wisdom and experience is about to gain
moment I'm actually telling you that I
think we're in the pre-dawn of it being
your game okay and I want to get that
into your head I really believe it I'm
not saying it to be nice it's I like to
watch and I think we're about to get
there and I think it's early I think
like I think I'll probably clip this in
11 years and be like told you like it's
going to take a little bit of time but I
think it's good for everyone to hear
that but for you specifically where you
are in your business life cycle because
I think you I hope not but I'm going to
be like very black and white on this I
think you should module and I think you
should Sell aggressively against the
modularization cuz I think you need the
answer because I think you're in a
pecuri spot because I think they're full
of [__] and there's none of them there's
six of them we don't need you we got it
internally we have a cheap diversity
officer we're good yeah you know so so
but the modularization my hope is that
it will work out and that you now do
have a 3K a month a 7K a month a 9k a
month and a 20K a month item and oh by
the way if you buy them all it's only
15K a month I think that's a worthwhile
thing I think it also will give you a
year of that data to then go back to
this back half of this conversation say
okay I might need to take what I am and
repackage it into some other business
and merchandise that that's what I was
thinking remember when you said to me uh
is a time management system it just
happens to be applied to Logistics yeah
maybe everything is correct yeah and you
might actually even like the business
you find yourself in more too that's
what's fun about entrepreneurship like
sometimes you don't realize a tweak
makes it more fun and more fruitful and
I I I love this when I got into it it's
just it's been a long time it's been a
long journey and markets change and it
has I love when everyone's like AI I
feel so bad for all the people that are
going to lose their job I'm like what
about all the people that sold Yellow
Pages we didn't feel bad for them when
search engines came you know many people
were in the business of selling Yellow
Pages tens and tens and tens of
thousands of people were sales men and
women just of Yellow Pages in America
when Yahoo and ask geves decided to come
along like [__] changes some poor dope
bought 5,000 horses the day before the
car decided to cause
trouble those horses became less
valuable so I think that it's
unfortunate because you should be
shining
well and what we found is when when
people are woke if you will yeah our
business doesn't do as well as we do
when they're not I know yeah I get it
the modularization awesome thank you
Scott so before I turn it over to my
wife I just want to say 20-year digital
veteran um CFO at I Village you remember
that name of course with the members of
the founding team at 360i amazing but
all on the finance side so it's okay
yeah sitting in a meeting where I'm
hearing operational activities we're
trying to figure out how to digitize
Market to our customer yes so I just
want to that's really cool time that's
awesome of course I do love that so hi
I'm Lori the other half yes um just
Scott created these for me after I had
breast cancer years ago so we donate
back to research um we have a product
we've proven our our model people people
Reby it stores buy it um we're in the
airports to 100 block brick and mortar
stores we're here to really how do we
expand our D Toc business um got it so
we we think that part of our issue is
that our our content our ugc we don't
think it's what it should be and um we
came in today talking about that we
don't really know who our target market
is we listened to a great section about
cohorts earlier which was hugely and
remember you know we touched on the
accordion nature of it did we touch on
that okay cool let me back to cohorts
and I almost notice how I knew that we
probably didn't talk enough about it the
best part about cohorts is that it's a
accordion the number one thing that you
have to understand about cohorts is that
it's a living and breathing vessel back
to day trading so cool like of course an
immediate cohort for this group is 18 to
22 year old Coastal workout Bros cuz
it's [__] protein balls like [__]
right but after we do 16 29 pieces of
creative that we think we've done well
enough if we're seeing absolutely zero
traction it is okay for that cohort to
go away if we PCS properly and read
everything one the most wild work I see
is when we pick a cohort we make for
them but the algo takes us in a
different direction we're like wait a
minute this is actually for offensive
linemen who fish and they pop them while
they fish so let's stand up you know you
know 18 to 30 year old 300 lb white boys
who love country music and work out and
like as you can imagine that's going to
be different content right so remember
with cohorts if you go down heavy it's
an accordion some expand some contract
based on the Quant and the qual the math
and the feedback that you read from the
PCS the reason I'm on to stuff always is
because I'm reading the qual my wisdom
thing is again not kindness for us for
get in here brother um you know it's for
I'm smelling it like there's the Tipping
Point you can smell it like
I had said earlier exactly that our our
customers are aged 2 to 92 but we're
your customers are anyone with a [__]
mouth right 100% that's what you're
saying okay keep going so um we do email
marketing successfully um we have a good
conversion rate so all they keep saying
is get us more traffic get more people
to the site so we have not done any paid
ads yet that's part of why we're here we
want to learn more about that we haven't
done paid ads or paid social okay I mean
or paid um search what we have done is
paid a our firm too much money to do
brand building everyone does that and
now we're taking that money and we're
want to re repurpose it into building
our brand more um we were told that you
should have one face and that I should
be making the content like like we were
just talking about um which does sound
like a big job but you know if we will
test it because if that's what people
want then you know I'll do it um it's
people like they taste the product they
like the product then they hear the
story then they're more connected I mean
the stor then they hear that we give
back to research and then it's done yeah
I mean the story is like so off the
charts reaching enough people 100% it
may be our content um it's it's every
like I'm not reaching enough people and
it's my content so what do you suggest
make more content like every like there
to me content like one day we will all
wake up and actually live in mixed
reality just I'll give you the preview
we will we will live in mixed route the
data is incredibly compelling the
technolog is very clear
the new [__] Facebook Rayband glasses
you've done it with the audio the new
one that just came out right it's like
earpods are in trouble like like you
know and that just like seems like yes
like so and when everyone wakes up every
one of you is going to regret not making
more content for social media because it
won't be where the attention is and just
like I regret not sending more emails in
'98 not buying more Google AdWords in
2002 not like so while we're in the era
where this is the predominant engine of
information back to advertising this is
what happened when the radio and the
television were switching literally
Budweiser is the biggest beer because
Schlitz and schaer and paps Blue Ribbon
blew it they kept holding on to the
radio and not realizing what the
television was doing it's insane if you
look from 1950 to 1970 the switch of the
biggest brands in every category from
cigarettes to diapers it's why Proctor
and Gamble's Proctor and Gamble they
were the biggest spender on television
do you know who the biggest spender on
Google AdWords was in the first five
years of AdWords Amazon there are
moments where there is this thing I
spoke about it in the micro with him Tik
Tok versus like that for you it's just a
macro back to why you considered hiring
some people to get you a mention in a
magazine got it yeah yeah or having you
show up on the Today Show you could be
on the Today show every day and you have
no chance against somebody who knows how
to make content for Tik Tok that's
that's the refocus so we we've been on
the
show that's the issue and we have an we
have an edge we're fresh from the fridge
um that we're not that's what happened
after I went through surgery and
treatment the nutritionist said no more
protein bars she said they sit on the
shelf for a year they have sugar soy
preservative so we have an angle we have
an edge um but we're not we haven't been
successful enough you know yet um how
old is the brand we our website's only
been um there for a year and a half and
before that you were selling in stores
really were're really pretty pretty new
yeah we were dipping our toe in it but
now you're ready to go all in and you
know I have a friend and she said get
rid of everybody get rid of your whole
payroll and and just do AI you know put
your content out on AI do your blogs on
AI did you ask her how I she sent me an
email she said she said I just made this
email for you in under two minutes yes I
think I think there's a lot to that I'm
going to go with like that's not the ex
I think we're intense in the right place
what's that go all in yeah I think you
got to go all in on things that actually
work you need a person yeah I mean look
I'm about AI I think the bigger issue is
everyone here is at the mercy of the
creative they put into the world so
couple things I think first of all now
I'm going to just kind of go like not
off script of the energy but let me make
pretend that Harwood invited us me to
dinner to have dinner with you and we're
like full dinner mode the number one
thing I would say for sure is that if I
could convince the two of you over this
dinner to do a daily or minimally a
weekly podcast so could be filmed for
Content I do believe the story is off
the charts it's going to pull at
everyone he's going to be like the most
loved man on earth like you know what I
mean he's a good man he looks like a
good man he's got a good face like I
feel the energy like all of us need to
do is find sustained ways to produce as
much content as possible and I think
what I figured out years ago was I'm
just going to film everything obviously
then it's about can you introduce new
people or different ideas like your
Spidey senses based on your words are
right the variable of your uccess will
be based on your advertising seems makes
sense what's crazy about the world we
live in now versus the Proctor world or
even when 360i was invented and Vayner
was invented is now the Walmarts right
the Wegman's the dream places of
distribution for you what's that [__]
place in La airwan you know like they
now will come to you if you're good at
content right it didn't work like that
back in the day so I think the biggest
thing that you have to your product is
comes very natural to me in my mind I
think in these terms I even said to
these guys like take your skills and
bring them to this show the prime the
beast's chocolate Beast like that's the
future like human based like this is
you're the future if you don't succeed
in this you will see someone that looks
exactly like you two with the similar
stories in 11 years and you're going to
look at each other these [__]
you know like it's very very clear that
you have to have a very compelling
organic social media presence what you
have to figure out that's easy that's
like you could you could have read that
in a million places how do you two even
if you two are not in it though that
would be my preference but I'm listen as
someone who's a public figure a lot of
[__] comes with that and it's not for
everyone and it's not right like it's
not for everyone and like and by the way
here's another thing real quick good for
you to hear as well you can also come in
and out people think like it's an all or
nothing thing sometimes you're a public
figure sometimes you're not some you
know like it's okay and you control your
narrative right like I keep my personal
life very private so it's not like you
have to tell them your pillow talk
you're in control but I think what you
have to do is put yourself in a position
to make as much like if I was your third
partner and this is what I did full-time
we'd probably put out 55 60 pieces of
creative a day across seven platforms
we're doing that with some of our
clients for
sure and there's like we can talk about
later to hijack this but there's very
cheap simple software tools that's what
I was going to say how do we incorporate
like us making the content how do we
find Initial Content Library like he
saiding you can't skip that part you got
to create all the content but then
getting it everywhere else now that's
where we're dipping ourselves in yeah
with and now with AI it's even better
than that I built a team of people who
had an eye for what to clip and when AI
is going to do all that like you're
going to upload the Raw videos and it's
going to spit it out and distributed for
you software right now clap k. apppp y
there's another one called get munch
we're going to talk yeah and by the way
I think all of you will he can give you
plenty that work for them here's even
and both are good I like both those
platforms let me give you something even
more fun there's a website called
Google and you type in AI software that
helps you clip videos into good social
media content enter what will happen
you'll get two paid ads probably for
weaker Pro sometimes week sometimes not
all you have to do is actually just
spend 10 hours with you would like this
business to be successful I have a funny
feeling that you can allocate 10 hours
to reading and watching video how do you
think we found them you're just
searching it's just you you got to put
in the work to find that but again yes
that is efficiency and efficiency
matters it's helpful for us to go from
zero to one like if you haven't created
content yet like get the library going
well I want to talk about what he's
touching on and where I'm really worried
I'm worried what always happens with
software is people think it does it for
you the when he says the video library
like you said it quick and he's right
because for him it's just sck nature of
like without that you have nothing you
on the receiving end is like oo let me
write down this site and I'm going to
use that's going to save me that's going
to do it it's not the part that I'm
saying is the well that's the the
software is the sync the well is do you
all understand how to put yourself in a
position to produce as much content as
possible no the reason I like podcasts
is
it puts you in a position to produce a
lot of content also when you have guests
now you can [__] prep for a podcast
so tell me about your childhood tell
tell how do you then what was your first
house like you're an hour in if you just
ask normal human questions but then you
have the clips so I think look I think
there's a lot of ways to think about it
there's other things I don't know you
two maybe you have a great 20 30 person
social crew and with a bunch of
extroverts you just might I don't know
you but if you do all of a sudden I see
this I'm like okay you need to throw at
I always think about two for ones like I
think for a lot of us there's probably I
I assume all of us are kind of like
similar in this it's very Universal I
don't think anyone spends as much time
with friends as they actually wish they
could like if you right it's just a
universal thing like everyone's busy
like to me let's say you two are just
like just we're talking about that that
you just aren't spending enough time
with these four couples you love my
brain goes to if we're lucky enough that
you're thinking that and we're luy
enough that those couples are
extroverted will willing to be filmed
now you can get together once a month
right and have a protein balls and
pairing with beverages literally
actually have one human who's filming
friend neighbor youngest kid or just set
up a tripad have dinner with eight of
your friends literally and this week
everyone bring a bottle of whisky and
we're going to do whiskey with protein
balls we're going to film and then
you're going to post produce at the end
be like all right 80% % of it we can't
share because the the Johnson's were
talking about how their daughter's a
piece of [__] and so that's but 20% you
can and now you're one Tik Tock away of
people falling in love that like Bullet
bourbon and this go great together and
then the next month again don't forget
what you're doing you're actually
spending time with friends but you're
getting double you're getting doubles
next time you're doing it with bottled
waters and next time with sodas and the
next time with clean Beverages and the
next time with protein shakes and the
next time with [__] juice that's
super press from organic [__] leaves
from the Amazon like I think for all of
us the big elephant in the room is do
you understand yourself do you not
[__] yourself are you self-aware
enough to know what puts me in the best
position to film as much [__] as
possible so I can post- produce it
because having a shoot day is already
like a different version of content
anyway and I'm not against it you can
supplement that with like one day when
you do like 37 call to actions you can
have a shoot day I think people are
accustomed to that but I think the big
one is can you put yourself in a
position to create
content content is your
[Music]
answer